>> Laura: MIDNIGHT DEADLINE TO
FILE YOUR 2018 TAXES JUST
MOMENTS AWAY AND THANKS TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THE MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS WILL BE KEEPING MORE
OF THEIR HARD-EARNED MONEY DUE
TO THE HISTORIC TAX REFORM.
THAT'S DESPITE, BY THE WAY, THE
ABSOLUTE LIES TOLD BY THE
LIBERAL MEDIA AND CERTAIN
DEMOCRATS.
>> WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS
DISHONEST IN TERMS OF TELLING
THE MIDDLE-CLASS THEY ARE
GETTING A TAX CUT ONE OF FACT
THEY ARE GETTING RICH OFF THEM.
>> 60% OF AMERICANS WILL SEE
THEIR TAXES GO UP BECAUSE OF
THIS BILL.
>> WHO WOULD'VE THOUGHT THEY
COULD'VE MADE IT LESS FAVORABLE
TO THE MIDDLE-CLASS AND MORE
SLANTED TOWARDS THE WEALTHY?
>> WHEN THEY SAID THIS TAX CUT
WOULD HELP MILLIE AS A PEOPLE,
THEY MEANT PEOPLE WITH MILLIONS.
>> Laura: COLBERT, THAT
ECONOMICS PhD.
THE ECHO CHAMBER OF NEGATIVE
NEWS ON THE TRUMP TAX CUTS IS
HAVING AN IMPACT ON THE VOTERS.
ACCORDING TO A NEW GALLUP POLL,
49% APPARENTLY DISAPPROVE OF THE
PRESIDENT'S TAX BILL.
40% APPROVE.
THAT'S THE HIGHEST APPROVAL FOR
THE MEASURES IN THE GALLUP
STARTED MEASURING REACTION.
FINALLY, THERE IS SOME PUSHBACK
TO THE LIES AND NOW EVEN THE
LIBERAL "NEW YORK TIMES" ADMITS
IT WAS WRONG, WRITING "THE GAP
BETWEEN PERCEPTION AND REALITY
ON THE TAX CUTS APPEARS TO FLOW
FROM A SUSTAINED AND MISLEADING
EFFORT BY LIBERAL OPPONENTS OF
THE LAW TO BRANDED AS A BROAD
MIDDLE-CLASS TAX INCREASE."
HUH.
JOINING ME NOW, LARRY KUDLOW.
HOW MUCH IS THE AVERAGE AMERICAN
SAVING THIS YEAR?
>> ABOUT $2300.
THAT'S A BIG NUMBER.
AVERAGE FAMILY OF $75,000 YEAR
WILL SAVE $2300.
THAT'S A VERY BIG NUMBER.
BUSINESSES ARE GOING TO SAVE
HUGE AMOUNTS OF MONEY, NOT JUST
BIG BUSINESSES BUT MEDIUM AND
SMALL BUSINESSES WHICH MAY BE
DRIVING THE ECONOMY RIGHT NOW.
THE MOST INCREDIBLE DROP IN
UNEMPLOYMENT IN 50 YEARS ACROSS
THE SPECTRUM, ALL MANNER OF
MINORITY GROUPS INCLUDING WOMEN
WHO ARE THE BIGGEST JOB GAINERS
LAST YEAR.
>> Laura: COULD YOU ARGUE THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION MIGHT NOT
HAVE DONE THE BEST JOB ON
SELLING WITH HIS TAX CUT WOULD
DO FROM THE BEGINNING?
TO HAVE THAT POLL NUMBER WITH
THIS ECONOMY WHERE IT IS AND
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS CALLING
ME.
A FRIEND OF MINE IS AN
ACCOUNTANT AND SAID THANK YOU,
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
AN EXTRA 3,000 OR $4,000 THIS
YEAR BECAUSE OF THE TAX CUT.
THOSE STORIES ARE EVERYWHERE
LOOK AT THE POLL, STILL PRETTY
LAME.
>> LET'S LOOK AT THIS.
TRUMP POLICIES, LOWER TAXES,
DEREGULATION, GOOD TRADE DEALS.
WE ARE IN A RISING TIDE OF
PROSPERITY.
POLICIES ARE REBUILDING THE
ECONOMY.
58% HARVARD HARRIS, GEORGETOWN
OR GEORGE WASHINGTON
BATTLEGROUND POLL AND NBC
"WALL STREET JOURNAL."
50% BELIEVE WE ARE IN A
POSITIVE, PROSPEROUS ECONOMY.
>> Laura: BERNIE SANDERS
TONIGHT WAS ON WITH MARTHA AND
BRET AND HE SAID YOU DON'T GET
ANY CREDIT FOR THIS ECONOMY,
LARRY.
LET'S WATCH.
>> DO YOU KNOW IT ON APPOINTMENT
IS IN GERMANY?
3.1%.
IN JAPAN IT'S 0.8%.
IN THE U.K.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE ENTIRE
GLOBAL ECONOMY, THANK GOD, IS
BOUNCING BACK FOR THE TERRIBLE
TERRIBLE WALL STREET DISASTER.
THE GLOBAL ECONOMY IS COMING
BACK AND UNEMPLOYMENT IS
RELATIVELY LOW.
TRUMP WILL GIVE A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT SPIN ON IT.
>> Laura: EARLIER HE SAID THE
PRESIDENT IS TRYING TO TAKE ALL
THE CREDIT.
HE BASICALLY DOESN'T DESERVE IT.
YOUR REACTION TO THAT.
THE REAL TRUTH OF THE G7 VERSUS
THE UNITED STATES.
>> THE G7, YOU CAN ARGUE GERMANY
-- I DON'T GET THAT, GERMANY IS
EITHER FLAT OR IN A RECESSION.
THE EUROZONE, FLAT OR IN A
RECESSION.
CHINA SLUMPING.
WE ARE THE HOTTEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD, GROWING 3% OR BETTER
WITH A 3.8% UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
WITH WAGES RISING.
MR. SANDERS NEGLECTED THIS, THE
BIGGEST BENEFICIARIES ARE THE
BLUE-COLLAR WORKERS, NOT THE
SUPERVISORS.
WE'VE NEVER SEEN BLUE-COLLAR
EMPLOYMENT WITH THIS IN 50
YEARS.
WAGE RATES ARE ABOUT 3%.
IN THAT COHORT, LOOK AT OVERALL
WAGES, THE BIGGEST GAINERS, THE
BLUE-COLLAR NONSUPERVISORY
WORKERS.
HE IS PRECISELY WRONG AND I'LL
GO BACK TO THIS POINT.
50% BELIEVE THAT WE ARE IN
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY FROM TRUMP'S
POLICIES.
TAX CUTS ARE A MEANS TO AN END.
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT THE DEBT?
$22 TRILLION.
BERNIE HIT THAT IDEA.
THE DEBT IS A KILLER.
HUGE SPENDING ADDED ONTO THE
ECONOMY.
>> WE WILL GROW UP AND HAVE BEEN
3% IN OUR ESTIMATES AND THAT IS
THE BEST MEASURE TO BRING DOWN
DEFICITS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO HAS THE
TOUGHEST BUDGET HE'S PUT OUT,
PERCENT CUTS IN THE DOMESTIC
SIDE.
IF THE SO-CALLED SPENDING CAPS
ARE NOT MET, WE ARE GOING TO
SEQUESTER ACROSS THE BOARD.
>> Laura: I SAY BRING BACK THE
SEQUESTER.
PETE BUTTIGIEG.
EVERYBODY HATES THE SEQUESTER.
I'M GLAD.
10% ACROSS-THE-BOARD.
>> THE TOUGHEST BUDGET.
BETTER GROWTH, MORE LIMITED
GOVERNMENT, THAT WILL HELP.
>> Laura: WHAT DO YOU THINK OF
BUTTIGIEG TALK ABOUT HOW
TRUMPETS TRY TO CAPTURE THE
MIDDLE OF AMERICA BUT IS SELLING
BASICALLY FEAR AND A BYGONE ERA
OF THE NEVER COMING BACK?
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GOING TO
END MIDDLE AMERICA.
THIS IS GOING TO BE -- LISTEN TO
THIS.
THIS IS GOING TO BE THE BIGGEST
ECONOMIC BIG TENT YOU'VE EVER
SEEN.
YOU GO DOWN THE LIST.
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, ASIANS,
WHITES, ADULT MEN AND WOMEN,
TEENAGERS.
THE UNEMPLOYED RATES ARE SO LOW
IN THE WAGES HAVE IMPROVED SO
MUCH AT THE LOWER END THAT THEY
ARE GOING TO COME INTO THE
TRUMP --
>> Laura: DEMOCRATS FREAK OUT.
ARE THEY FREAKING OUT?
BIG LEANNE, ALL THE HARD HATS,
ALL THE CONSTRUCTION GUYS,
BUILDING PIPELINES, OR OPENING
UP TRADE DEALS THAT ARE GOING TO
HAVE FARMERS, RANCHERS --
>> Laura: ARE THEY GOING TO
LIVE UP TO THOSE PROMISES?
BETTER NOT BECAUSE I'LL BE
COMING AFTER YOU.
>> THE BIGGEST WINNERS AND THAT
WILL BE FARMERS AND RANCHERS.
ORDINARY FOLKS PRAISE.
WE'VE GOT TO GO.
>> USMCA DEAL.
WE DO BERNIE, BERNIE, BERNIE IS
-- I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU.
>> LET'S DO IT.
ONE LAST ONE.
>> Laura: GOT TO GO.
GOT TO GO.
>> SENATOR SANDERS.
180 MILLION AMERICANS WILL LOSE
THEIR PRIVATE INSURANCE UNDER
SANDERS.
HE WILL TAKE OUT 15% OF THE GDP
INSIDE OF TEN YEARS AT THE VERY
MOMENT WHERE WE HAVE A NEW
PROSPERITY CYCLE FROM TRUMP
POLICIES, HE WANTS TO TURN IT
BACK INTO A DEEP RECESSION.